, AN OF NOW,-1A OT EVERY YEAR, H
WE KNOW COAWHOW IMPORTAN IPEOPLE
>> LET ME BREA
I KNOWE ARTIRE
D AND BOTER
SHOTS.TH BROADLY T
R.
YOU WANT TO MAED TVE CN THE ENT.
WE ARE IN THE
FALL
WE'RE G FROM THE FDAION TO WHA
RIHOT GET THCO WS HETH
DATED VACCINE.
>> THERENCES
SH GIVENROICULAR.THINTELYDEAL.
DO A GOOD JOB WITT LAST TIME W
VACCI THINK THIS TIME CD
JUST BE VERY CLEARMPR EVERYBODYR
20-YEAR-OLD ATET OLD PERSONE
COVID IS STILLAN
IN TF THE VACCINES, CAFLIG
CATIME.ME,  YYOU, KNOW PECOVI
IN TT,E
OVERTHR U GET
ME T TO'OUSTRSMALY T AT
SAME TIME.ITD RECOMMEND THAT IFY
THE FOLLOWING WEEK GET THE UTGE
RARELY CAT BOTHMERECOD  ODREAD
COVID,YS HE'N  DOEE NE KNOVARIA
TH.ATNT
IA
THEY GEE THEY'VE TESTED TCE. S.
BUT THATECAUSE THE
NOT CK THE N OMICRON
TESTYOU HAVE T
O CALLT
BIOPSYYOU'REO BE'S PAINFUL FOR A
PEOPLE ARE NOT GT DEEP, YES, TH
RSV, COVID,NDT.
THREE THINGSO WORRY ABOUT.
T DIS
TEOF SYMPTOMS AT ALLH THN INFECE
THAT CLSTIGUE,
ITOUUG RSV IT TH
NTS,LL IHA GUISH BETWEEN BH OF .
UPLE
GET THE PCTEST.
EVERYBODY, BUT IT'S WAY MORE N E
T
PRONUNCIATION, BUT
IN
>> THERE ARE
OVER-THENT OIOE
FLON
FENNELEST RIN
STRONGERSE ATR
DRUGMA MPRODUCTS YOUIONED.
BILLION 00 MILLI  WERE